Reasons why you might not be happy in your relationship.
Number one, you stop doing the little things for each other.
Those things that you did in the beginning of the relationship
that made you create that spark within each other stopped.
Stop treating your partner special.
The spark dies down.
You stop thanking each other for all the little things that they do
to make your life more bearable.
The second you do that,
it's not really worth their time to continue doing that.
So do not forget to thank them
and appreciate them for being in your life.
3. You got comfortable.
This is normal when you're in a long term relationship
to fall in a comfortable pattern.
Stop trying so hard. They stop pouring into your relationship.
You stop planning the dates,
you stop setting the flirty tech up,
getting cute for each other,
and you stop being playful.
Why can't you fall into this comfort mode
that I don't have to put too much energy in?
My relationship mode is the second your relationship suffers.
Stop looking forward to seeing each other,
you start arguing more, and maybe worse of all,
your intimacy, physically and emotionally suffers.
If you don't want a failing relationship,
do not forget to put in the effort.